hi it's Larry here Xbox Live's matron
else I'm really excited to share this
with you this is the Xbox one X project
Scorpio edition that we are announcing
today and will be available for
pre-order today as well now I have these
special white gloves which are gonna
allow me to dig in and do an unboxing
but I want to show you the Box first
because this is beautiful this is the
beautiful packaging which leans into the
heritage of Xbox here we see the Xbox
screen for those fans that have been
with us for a while they're gonna notice
the X on the front it looks like the
original Xbox doesn't it of course
earlier this year we announced original
Xbox coming to back compat here you can
kind of see it hinted in this xbox 1x
super limited edition packaging so what
do you say we jump into it let's take a
look at what we have in the box of
course we have a trial for game pass and
Xbox Live Gold will be included in this
box over here you'll find the stand
which I've already got attached this box
over here we're going to include the
controller batteries are included a high
speed 4k capable HDMI cable and then we
have the console but not just any
console this is the world's most
powerful console 4k gaming 6 teraflops
this thing as you know is a beast look
at the front look at this beautiful
graphic design we have the Xbox screen
on both the console as well as the
controller project Scorpio Edition this
is lovely alright now we get a good shot
at this let me spin it around here so
you can see the beautiful beautiful
design on the front the precision and
the dots is kind of a gradient all the
way down again heritage showing the
power this is the world's most powerful
console and you need a design to show
that off and that's what the project
Scorpio Edition does you can see it
right here look how beautiful it is and
here we have the controller you can see
it says project Scorpio on the front of
course the Xbox green is there which is
great to see for folks that know the
Xbox screen with these beautiful premium
buttons now I also want to point out
that all your existing Xbox one
controllers will work perfectly with
Xbox one X and of course the Xbox one X
Project Scorpio edition isn't it
beautiful
alright let's turn it around and take a
look at the ports back here of course if
you have an Xbox one s you'll already
recognize the ports there in precisely
the same order as your Xbox one is so
you can drop this into your home
entertainment system unplug it from the
Xbox 1s plug it into the X
Fox 1x we're gonna make it easy to move
all your content over and you're gonna
be ready to go what's really cool is we
have some design touches back here as
well you'll notice that the HDMI out has
a little little bump on it so you know
when you're feeling back there you know
exactly what port to plug it in to
everything is exactly the same it's
going to be very very familiar and
that's a look at the Xbox one X project
Scorpio edition now everything in the
standard edition is included in the
project Scorpio edition but here you get
this beautiful graphic you get the xbox
green and this exclusive stand now I'm
happy to share it is available for
pre-order today so get your pre-order in
because once it's gone this is gonna be
gone for good
my name is Larry herb Xbox Live's Major
Nelson thanks for watching